hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his treaties on virtues and vices
alcuin of york is going to focus
primarily
on a by that time fairly long
established schema of the eight capital
vices or the eight principal vices as
he's also going to call them
here
and this is an idea that eventually is
going to morph through gregory of the
greats morali on job into the now
familiar seven deadly sins so if you
have been looking at the the names of
these you know gluttony lost pride and
you're like oh that sounds like the
seven deadly sins there's a very good
reason for that there are two you could
call them complementary but also
somewhat rival
uh arrangements of the key or capital
things that lead us astray the eight
capital vices the seven deadly sins
there's a lot of overlap between the two
of them and it's a really central idea
in christian morality that comes from
monastic literature the monks who are
thinking about this the first person to
really focus on this is ivagrius
ponticus who views these as eight bad
thoughts that demons implant into our
minds
by the time that john cassian is going
around the desert monasteries in egypt
palestine before that but primarily
egypt and having these conferences with
some of the abbots there
there's already a
well-established uh teaching you could
call it of the eight capital vices and a
lot of this is sort of experiential this
is identifying the main ways that people
go off the the correct path and get
themselves into all sorts of trouble so
by the time that alcuin himself is
writing about this to count guy
you would have both the eight capital
vices out there and the seven deadly
sins both as understandings of this very
complementary to each other and you know
it's worth spending a little bit of time
on this why are they called the seven
deadly sins they're not deadly in the
sense that if you do them you're gonna
die or something like that they are
deadly because just like the eight
capital vices they lead to so many other
sins or vices or iniquities wickednesses
ways of going
wrong and so in chapter 27
alkawin is going to tell us
there are eight principle
vices or the originals and he uses that
that term of all vices and he uses a
metaphor here
they are like roots so if you don't do a
lot of gardening you may not know about
this but there are some plants
where you can cut them back as often as
you want if the root is still there it's
going to spring back i mean you've
probably seen this with trees that have
been cut down and a shoot comes out
dandelions are like this you know you
have to be very careful to pull the
whole root out or else you know it's not
going to do you any good to cut the
dandelion there's many many plants like
this and that's great if we want those
plants to grow
if
it's vices bad character traits within
us the not just lack of the virtues but
things that are opposed to the virtues
well then this is a problem and and
people encounter this all the time if we
take for example lust right if you are
struggling with lust and you say all
right i'm not going to
you know look at pornography as a matter
of fact i'm actually not even going to
look at things where there's people who
could be attractive when i'm in the
you know grocery store and i see those
those magazines over there
tv guide there could be somebody
attractive on that i'm gonna avert my
eyes
well
that may not actually
cut off the problem at the roots right
and we could say similar things for
wrath getting angry oh i'll just not
express my anger when people get me
riled up oh you all you're gonna stuff
it down inside you're actually
fertilizing the root in that case so we
need to actually
pull out the roots he says and cut off
the shoots if we want to follow this
metaphor out and he calls these um vices
that will generate other vices of
diverse iniquities or diverse
unreasonableness
and he uses that you know uh term
uh
iniquity meaning wickedness ways in
which we're being bad
and they affect both the mind and the
body the corrupted mind and the unchaste
body now i do want to point something
out that is not being mentioned in this
treatise but is a basic assumption of
the monastic literature on virtues and
vices and that is
that is that the
corruptions of the mind the vices of the
mind are much much worse
than those of the body it's not good to
be lustful it's not good to be
gluttonous
but those pale in comparison to greed or
vain glory
or spiritual sadness or wrath or any of
those other things which are much more
dangerous much more serious for the the
people who understand this correctly
so
what are these different
eight capital vices again you'll
recognize a lot of the seven deadly sins
in them
gluttony gula you know stuff in your
face eating more than you ought to and
he's got some discussions that uh
specify gluttony a little bit more that
we'll we'll talk about elsewhere
lost now not libido in latin but
fornication where there's a little bit
more emphasis on the doing right
fornication
is you know within the medieval
christian
scheme of things basically screwing
anybody or anything
that isn't your spouse
right and and you know also it could
extend to having sex with them in the
wrong ways you know uh
or even the wrong times you know maybe
you're not supposed to do it when you're
fasting or something like that but lust
lust and gluttony both are corporeal
bodily
uh sins that lead to other sins right so
you know your sin for lust might lead
you to or your vice of lust might lead
you to acting like a greedy bastard and
uh trying to make as much money as you
can so you can frequent prostitutes or
you know similar thing with gluttony
right oh i gotta eat the best food i'm a
foodie i need a lot of money so i can do
that or it might lead to you know
treating people badly you know there's
all sorts of possibilities
avarice or greed now we start getting
into spiritual sins avaritsya
very problematic uh from
the perspective of anybody who buys into
these in part because there is that
passage the love of money is the root of
all evil coming from one of paul's
letters and so there's a long debate in
christian uh thought about you know how
central avarice is
anger era and and if it bothers you to
think that all anger could be bad just
call it wrath instead right because that
could also translate ira
anger gets us in a lot of trouble and it
leads to a lot of other
vices and sins
weariness acadia a distractedness is
another way
of putting it this was something that
fell out of the seven deadly sins
because it got rolled into sloth along
with sorrow or tristitia but it was
recognized as a significant problem
by these monastic teachers sorrow as
well
not all sadness is necessarily bad
but there is a kind of sorrow that keeps
you from doing what you ought to do that
distracts you and that might be why
weariness and sorrow could be rolled
into the one
vice of sloth in gregory's account that
is not here in alcan alcuin actually
treats these as
separate problems and then we get to two
that are kind of similar to each other
but also different
vein glory
which in latin is canodoxia coming
directly from the greek meaning empty
glory right vain means empty or
meaningless or something like that it's
also vana gloria right is another way of
talking about it and this is where you
you know you're you're jockeying for
social status you want people to like
you you want more than you should you
want people to recognize you you need to
be the one who's in the spotlight you
need to be the one who's getting the
awards or if we're talking about social
media you need to be re-shared and have
people talking about you all the time
and then finally pride superbia
pride you might say well isn't that the
same thing as vainglory well for these
monastic authors no they're kind of
similar in that you can you know be
prideful or vain glorious about any of
your achievements but pride
really amounts to wanting to throw off
any rule any governance by anybody else
you want to be your own boss
and to you know be greater than others
as as well and not just in the sense of
glory but to think of yourself as
perhaps the center of the universe
alkaline tells us that the very
first vice the most principal vice
is spiritual and it is pride and he
talks about this here he says about
which is said pride is the start of all
sins the queen of all evils through
which the angels fell from heaven which
happens from contempt of the mandates of
god okay so that's you know angels and
stuff like that how does it apply to us
human beings
it happens when the mind is raised about
its good works and thinks itself better
than others when in fact it is worse
than others by the fact that it reckons
itself better it also happens through
obstinacy when people despise
obeying their lords
you know so when we don't recognize the
proper authorities over us and that
could be you know all sorts of things i
mean we don't all have lords but if you
go to the doctor and you're like i'm
gonna boss my doctor around and tell
them how my treatment ought to be
you're being kind of prideful right if
you go to uh
your kids teachers and you're like i
think i know more about education than
you do i'll i'll decide what the
curriculum is going to be you're kind of
being a prideful jerk in that case right
so the first vice is spiritual the first
corporeal
vice
is gluttony you know wanting to eat too
much and here
alkane actually says something kind of
interesting he says
through which the first parents of the
human race lost the felicity of paradise
and were ejected into the wretched
misery of this life where every person
is born through sin
lives through work dies through
sorrow so it you know now this is not a
typical
point of view
but alcuin is connecting together this
primal disobedience
with
wanting to eat the fruit by the way
no no notion of whether it's an apple or
a quince or whatever it just says the
fruit of that tree right in in the
biblical text
now the last thing to say about each of
these eight capital vices
uh oh i do have to mention one other
thing so envy envy is discussed in the
um treaties on the virtues and vices in
chapter 22
envy
is one of the seven deadly sins
it is not in the list of the eight
capital vices
however
john cassian does discuss envy and
alkaline does discuss it
as well
so you know that's kind of an outlier
there in any case each of these vices
has some virtues opposed to them
as remedies and he talks about this
at the very end of the chapter that's
number 34
about cain odoxia that is vain glory so
he says that pride is conquered through
humility
gluttony through abstinence
fornication or lost through chastity
avarice interestingly enough here is
conquered through
wisdom now in a lot of other treatises
avarice is conquered through
charity or generosity but here it's
conquered through wisdom which
presumably would lead to
that
um
anger is conquered through patience
uh
weariness or or acadia is conquered
through constancy of good works making
yourself persevere in them
bad sadness is conquered through
spiritual joy
then vainglory through the charity of
god
so charity
karitas love is doing a different job
here than it often does
it is helping us to overcome
vain glory and all of these virtues that
he talks about are all associated under
the cardinal virtues the
four main virtues of practical wisdom or
prudence
uh justice fortitude or courage and
temperance or
moderation so these eight vices are very
important to identify
and to struggle against in alkynes
on virtues and vices
you